The Office for National Statistics tells
us that in a decade's time there'll be
even more of us in England than we
thought up to sixty million people and
most of the newcomers will be immigrants
pressure groups claim that'll mean more
pressure on roads schools and hospitals
so I'll be waiting for yet another tube
train before I can squeeze under
somebody's armpit and get to work but
without young immigrants who's gonna do
all the new jobs in tech and who's going
to pay me next pension I think we've got
three choices we could go German okay
let a million young folk in and spend
billions teaching them the language
building new homes buying more trains
and I can retire one day or we could
turn Japanese put up the walls maintain
our culture and build robots to do the
new jobs and look after the old folks
but we probably still have to work
pretty much forever or we could all just
have one child as the policy in China
and then we definitely have to work till
we dropped so sauerkraut sushi or spring
rolling well I'm one of six children by
the way my parents we haven't got to
contraception yet
because it's become a bit of immigration
migration has become a dirty word in
various different places when you even
try to have a sensible conversation
about the things that we're trying to
discuss now I do think you almost get
sideswipes very very quickly she's a
racist he's a racist they're a racist
they're talking about migration and
immigration which I think has been
really unhelpful because I think what we
need to do is as a country particularly
if I use the word if we are going to
break say anytime soon and I'm not
holding my breath on that one but we do
need to have sensible conversations
about immigration strategies what that
looks like kind of immigration that we
want and I think that's failed very much
so we have had we've had conversations
about whether we can restrict
immigration to tens of thousands which
have absolutely failed we've had
conversations around prioritization of
EU Nationals versus non and I think we
need to go right back to the basics and
look at what is it as a society we want
to be like we want to look like and to
your point you know you know obviously
you'd never go down the one-child policy
of China but I think you raised some
quite interesting societal conversations
as well about places like Japan where
they do very much care for their elders
and we don't tend to so much and I think
that we need to look at immigration cite
an ounce of you by the way yeah if you
think he's end of my thing I've got the
solution I I don't but I very much
welcome these sensible conversations
about immigration and the strategy and
the plans that we want to put in place
to be to be clear I'm basically a
sauerkraut man I think you know we will
have to will have to accept young people
into the country and you know Nick and I
need to get off the telly quite soon but
the point I'm really making is we need
to stop putting off the choice and
that's what we do every single day I
think I think Germany I think there
needs to be a less sour crack that's not
on steroids it was the speed and the
intensity of of the sort of you nut
machine
David Frum recently wrote a piece for
The Atlantic addressing this very
subject and actually he faced a huge
backlash so he had to write a response
piece whose original piece because his
basic intention was to write try and
write a sensible conversation around
immigration and it was very caveat and
I've ridden I've written I've written
read both the original and the response
and he was at pains to try and be
nuanced about it to your point because
obviously the conversation is fraught
but but still yet he faced a backlash
one of the dangers he raises in there
with a sauerkraut model is of course the
AFD Rose in Germany I'll and gained in
town to the point now where the second
largest block in the parliament we've
got to do this in a way that doesn't
lead to that result it's so far in every
case it's led to that I've raised this
as an age question you guys have gone
straight to immigration you guys won't
do say maybe we need to because the
reason that we this country has the
fifth or sixth is because of how many
young people have been attracted in many
cases young Europeans not exclusively
but young Europeans have come to cities
such as London and others a mansion of
burning and my god they put in a shift
and they drive the economy we cannot
afford to lose that that being said in a
way Magister a lot of my thunder you
can't honestly point to what Angela
Merkel did in the way she did it as a
success because it was it divided
society there are still stories and
counter stories of whether some
immigrants did or did not try and sell
find our people in Cologne on a certain
music and I don't think it will ever be
resolved but you go to some cities now
in Germany I am told I'm told on
reliables and there really is a nasty
tension because a lot of these people
who were brought in haven't been found
jobs haven't sort jobs and it is a very
divided society
can't someone as wise and sage as you
are in these Affairs you couldn't
possibly sign off on that I'll be quick
I agree with you I think long-term the
sauerkraut model is the right model
short term you have the backlash that
these two have described the Japanese
model certainly doesn't work they've got
some of the highest suicide rates in the
world and as we know that 16 years old
and the China model doesn't work because
now we've got a hundred million
shortfall in women so they're actually
going to have to bring in immigration to
try and marry off some of the men in
that country I think what we need to
look at is I don't personally think
immigration so much is the problem I
think it's how it's done it needs to be
staggered and then the other thing as
well is in order to be able to plan for
your public services and so on you need
to know what numbers are coming in which
was the problem with freedom of movement
we didn't know how many we're going to
be coming in so I think that long term
is the sauerkraut model were the only
two on the board that raises has to be
looked at and actually Crom themselves
are gonna have to look at it because
there is we're getting into obsession
about question and we have a choice to
make
the Germans our saw the Germans made a
decision the Germans said whether you
like whether you like it or not if we
don't get more young people we've got no
choice and they're spending something
like 20 billion you
on language to deal with the problems of
integration my criticism is we keep
dodging the question what are we gonna
do for example in 2016 there 1.6 million
of us of people of us or over 85 by 20
66 there'll be 5.1 million now we have
to make a choice do we focus on helping
the old people and by constructing the
economy in such a way that it works for
them or do we just expand the economy by
bringing more people in and hope that
that will pay for you and me to get old
there's only one choice trevor which is
that choice it's just nobody wants to be
honest about it and really the thing we
have to look at is how we do it you know
it's got to be a staggered approach ya
know that's it I think that I was gonna
heart come back to something you said
earlier about freedom of movement I
think actually the debates moved on
since then what I will say is hopefully
by 20 it's at 66 you said Trevor
hopefully by then there also be some
advances in automation and technology
which will help our economy out a bit
you know with a more automated economy
of course though that creates other
knock-on effects when it comes to labor
and laying off people in the sorts of
industries that have become automated so
I think we're headed to a few crises